-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Ike Barinholtz,
everybody.
And congratulations.
"History of the World"
premiered this week.
It's so funny.
This is based on the classic
Mel Brooks film...
-Yep.
-...who was a producer on it.
So here you are with...
-Look at that.
-...Nick Kroll, Wanda Sykes,
our dear friend, handsome boy,
Dave Stassen.
And what was it like
to take this on as a project?
-I mean, look at that.
We look like we're in a '50s
doo-wop crew, you know?
"It's the Forks!"
[ Laughter ]
It was amazing.
Mel is a legend.
He's still funnier
than any of us at 96.
And he came to the premiere,
and he gets up there.
No one knew he was gonna come.
They're all surprised.
And he gets up there and he
goes, "I just want you to know,
on my drive over here tonight,
I listened to the radio.
And as I look at you all
right now, you need to know
we're going to have continued
showers for the next two days.
And there's a low-pressure front
moving in from Canada."
[ Laughter ]
Amazing.
-You know, we saw in the clip,
you play Ulysses.
-Yes.
-Ulysses S. Grant.
-Yeah.
One of our hottest presidents.
-And I will say --
[ Laughter ]
You know, I met you almost --
I mean, like,
almost 30 years ago now.
-Oh, my God.
-And if someone had said,
"He's gonna do one
of two things --
he's gonna win
'Celebrity Jeopardy!'
or play Ulysses S. Grant."
[ Laughter ]
And the fact that you did two
in the same, like, month.
-That's crazy.
-Yeah.
But you actually -- He's --
You dig him.
-I love him.
He's the reason
we don't all say "y'all."
-Yeah.
-You know?
I don't want to say "y'all."
I like saying "you all."
"Are you all going to come?"
-Yeah.
-I'm not in a hurry.
-Nobody likes
hearing you say "y'all."
-No! They get mad when I say it,
so I give Grant props to that.
-Now, this is --
this is maybe my favorite.
There's an incredible cast.
-Amazing cast.
We got everyone.
We got Dove Cameron,
Zazie Beetz, Jay Ellis,
Taika Waititi, Jack Black.
But we had one name --
-I mean, I can't believe
you got him.
Now, we're going to show
his head shot in a minute,
because this is --
this is a cameo,
and, I mean, I recognized him,
but people might not,
'cause he's an up-and-comer.
-He's a new ingenue
in Los Angeles.
And his name is my dad.
-Yeah.
-And --
-So that's Alan Barinholtz.
-Alan Barinholtz.
That's not what
he really looks like.
He's wearing a big
prosthetic suit there,
which he hated and complained
about the entire time.
But he was --
You know him very well.
He was a lawyer his whole life.
-Yep.
-And then --
-He was like the --
Like, for real, whole life.
Born a lawyer.
Like, he was --
He looks like a man who was --
If I ever saw his baby picture,
I would assume it would be like,
"At law."
-Yeah. You know, his first word
was "amicus brief."
But he -- he wanted to act, but
he was a lawyer his whole life.
And then last year,
long story short,
a friend of ours reached out
and was like,
"Hey, we're doing a pilot.
And it's a courtroom comedy,
and we thought maybe your dad
could put himself on tape
to be the judge."
So we put him on tape.
And my brother and I were like,
"He's kind of good."
And he booked it.
[ Laughter ]
And it wasn't a pilot,
it was a series,
eight episodes for Amazon.
It's called "Jury Duty."
-Yeah.
-And apparently,
he's amazing in it.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone I know --
-So, this is your dad, who lived
in Chicago, was never an actor.
-Lawyer.
-Now lives in L.A.
-Lives in L.A.
-Has a head shot.
-Head shot.
Head shot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that.
That is an actor for hire
right there.
It used to be
when he would come over,
he'd be like,
"Oh, how are the kids?
Did you see the game?
It was amazing."
Now it's like, "If you have
five minutes to put me on tape,
that would be really great.
I'm auditioning
for Gus Van Sant."
I'm like, "Alright."
-I mean, it's a wonderful story,
because you and your brother are
both actors, and the fact --
I mean, he must have looked at
you long enough and been like,
"You know what?
They --
I didn't get it from them,
they got it from me.
So if they're actors, I should
get out there and do it."
-Well, I just like that,
you know,
everyone's mad
about nepo babies now.
This is a reverse nepo baby.
-Yeah.
-This is a nepo parent,
which is a good thing.
-You've got a nepo dad.
-I've got a nepo dad.
Which everyone likes a nepo dad.
It's like, "Oh, wow,
second career, good for him."
No one's like, "Oh, these
nepo dads are taking my work!"
-I mean, again -- And I feel
like I've said a lot of things
that imply negativity towards
you, but I will just say,
I'm happy your dad late in life
decided to become an actor
than you decide
to become a lawyer.
-It's never too late, Seth.
In fact, I would like
to announce tonight
that I have opened
my own boutique law firm.
If you follow me on Instagram
and send me a DM
with your legal problem...
-What sort of things
are you focused on most?
What kind of law?
-Oh, I love it all.
I love it all.
I love probate, family law.
-Oh, that's great.
And you passed the bar?
-Bar pending.
Bar pending.
But soon -- soon enough.
I'm studying really hard,
I swear.
-That's great, and you're going
to take the California bar.
-I'm taking the California bar,
the New York --
any state that will have me.
-Oh, that's lovely.
-If your state has a bar,
I'm gonna take it,
which is the catchphrase
for my law firm.
-Oh, that's right.
-So if you can give me a call,
I'm here to support you
in your time of need.
-You're coming off a little
needy when you keep saying,
"If you could give me a call."
-If you guys
could give me a call,
I have a deal with a company
that I get paid
every time you call.
-AT&T?
-I just signed a new deal
with AT&T friends and family,
unlimited plan, not Saturdays.
-That's really exciting.
Thank you, buddy.
It's great to see you.
You guys, Ike Barinholtz!
"History of the World, Part II."
Streams on Hulu, with new
episodes premiering daily
through March 9th.
We'll be right back
with Melissa Barrera.